Traductor: Cristina Conesa Carbonell
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Cuando tenía 7 u 8 años
mis papás me subieron al carro.
Yo sabía lo que significaba.
Ellos encendieron el carro
y empezamos a ir por una carretera.
Sabía que significaba que
me llevaban al pueblo de mi abuela.
Y el pueblo de mi abuela está perdido
en medio de las montañas.
Ahí en la ciudad de la Paz.
Mientras íbamos yo me ponía más triste.
Por la ventana veía
ese camino serpenteante
casi infinito, que parecía hecho
por una serpiente.
Mientras avanzábamos
yo me ponía un poquito más triste.
Cuando llegamos al pueblo de mi abuela
mi abuela estaba en la puerta
como siempre, ahí sentadita,
como esperando.
Al poco rato mis papás me bajaron.
Se pusieron a hablar con ella
y yo me ponía más y más triste.
De repente mis papás se subieron al carro
y se fueron.
Claro, yo a mis 7-8 años
tenía que quedarme con ella
a ayudar con las labores del campo.
Cuando veía
que el minibús se iba alejando
Yo me ponía más y más triste.
Estaba a punto de llorar.
Cuando siento por atrás
que alguien se va acercando.
Y era mi abuela.
Se va acercando
y de repente se acerca
y me abraza y me abraza y me abraza
y acerca su rostro al mío
y puedo sentir sus arrugas,
ese sudor que tenía,
porque en ese lugar
hacía mucho pero mucho calor.
Entonces siento sus arrugas, el sudor,
se está frotando contra mí y yo le digo:
"Abuela, ¿por qué me estás abrazando?"
Y la abuela me mira y me dice:
"Mi hijito, es para alejar el frío."
"¿Cuál frío, abuela? ¡Son 30 º C!"
"¡Estás loca, abuela!"
Y la abuela sonríe y me sigue abrazando.
Y en la noche, en la cama
que me habían asignado,
Estoy ahí echadito...
Cuando, de repente, tengo esa tristeza
que nos inunda cuando uno está solo
Y tengo ganas de llorar,
y mi abuela que tal vez sabía esas cosas
se baja de la cama, se mete
a la mía, me abraza otra vez
me abraza, me abraza...
y siento sus arrugas y el sudor otra vez
y me dice: "Hijito, ¿estás bien?"
Y yo: "No, abuela,
¿por qué me estás abrazando?"
"Hijito, es para alejar el frío."
"¡Abuela, hace 30 º C de calor!
¿Cuál frío? ¿Estás loca, abuela?"
Y realmente, cada vez
que me sentía triste,
se acercaba, me abrazaba,
y decía que era para alejar el frío.
Realmente yo creí
que mi abuela estaba muy loca.
Pero hace muchos años atrás,
mi abuela falleció.
Y en el entierro, yo veía a mi abuela
y le daba el último adiós.
Me ponía a pensar en tantas
cosas que me había dicho
y recordé esto que les estoy contando.
Y entonces, entendí.
Entendí que mi abuela me abrazaba con ese
cariño, con esa fuerza, a pesar del calor,
y lo hacía, lo hacía para alejar el frío,
el frío del corazón.
Soy narrador de cuentos,
soy cuentacuentos.
Y he venido a hablarles justamente
de cuentos, de historias.
Desde el momento que abrimos los ojos,
somos protagonistas de una historia.
Una historia que vivimos y transformamos
con cada acción que tomamos.
Pero al mismo tiempo somos
el narrador, y la narradora,
que cuenta esta historia
al mundo que nos rodea.
Entonces la pregunta va:
Cuando contamos nuestra historia,
¿qué palabras usamos para transmitirla?
¿Somos capaces de identificar aquello
mágico y especial que vivimos día a día,
y que nos transforma?
Estas preguntas nacen de dos
únicas preguntas.
La primera: ¿quién soy?
Y la segunda: ¿qué sabe el mundo de mí?
Y aunque contestar a estas preguntas
es lo más complicado que hay,
yo tengo que darles un secreto
de todos los cuentacuentos del mundo,
cuál es este secreto al momento
de contar una historia.
Hace tiempo tuve una de las experiencias
más lindas en mi vida de cuentacuentos.
Estaba saliendo de una universidad,
ahí con la mochila al hombro,
había tenido una función bellísima
y estaba feliz y contento caminando
cuando siento que alguien
me toca el hombro.
Me giro y era una chica
como de este tamaño.
Se me acerca y me dice
si le podía contar otro cuento.
Yo le digo: "¡Claro!"
Porque yo con mi principio de narrador
tengo la visión de contar cuentos
a quien sea, a cualquier persona
que me lo pida.
Y le digo: "¡Listo!"
Nos vamos a un cafecito, nos sentamos,
y, antes de empezar, se me ocurre algo.
Y le digo: "Hagamos un trato."
"Yo te cuento una historia,
si al terminar tú me cuentas otra."
Ella, de forma tímida, acepta.
Entonces yo le cuento
lo que les acabo de contar.
Cuando termino, le digo:
"Bueno, es tu turno."
Ella me mira, junta los hombros para
dentro, sigue mirando y muy tímida dice:
"Es que yo no tengo nada que contar."
"No me pasa nada interesante."
¿Les suena?
Yo, como cuentacuentos,
la miro y le digo:
Voy a recurrir al viejo truco de todos
los cuentacuentos del mundo...
"Cuéntame la historia de tu primer amor."
Ella me empieza a contar una historia
y, mientras me va contando,
yo la voy escuchando
y le voy preguntando ciertos detalles
que a veces se nos escapan.
Cuando termina, yo le digo:
"¿Quieres que te cuente otra historia?"
Ella me dice que sí.
Entonces le empiezo a contar la historia
que me había contado ella hace dos minutos
Y se la sigo contando, y sigo contando.
Ella va abriendo los ojos y
se va emocionando y emocionando.
Y cuando termina la historia,
una historia que termina
con un beso, una canción
y una traición,
ella se queda quieta,
disfruta,
luego, me mira y me dice:
"¿De verdad me pasó todo esto a mí?"
Yo le digo: "Sí te pasó todo esto a ti."
Y entonces hace una pausa y me
hace una pregunta que nunca olvidaré:
"¿Y cómo es que yo
no puedo contarla así?"
¿Saben?
Cuando nos dicen "¡Cuéntame algo!"
decimos que no tenemos nada que contar,
que lo mágico y especial y único
le está pasando a alguien
al otro lado del mundo.
Está pasando al otro lado de la tele.
Pero eso no es cierto.
Nos pasan cada cosa mágica, especial,
única, poética... ¡cada cosa!
Pero lo que pasa es que realmente,
al momento de contarla,
no tenemos el valor o no aceptamos
eso que nos está pasando.
Y estamos peleados con
nuestra propia historia.
Entonces, yo les propongo:
Qué tal si un día nos invitamos al cine,
otro día nos invitamos a comer,
un día nos invitamos a un café,
nos sentamos con nosotros y
empezamos a conversar.
Detengámonos un segundo para ver
si realmente cada cosa que hemos vivido
es linda, es hermosa.
Y yo les aseguro, que lo es.
Porque dicen que aquello que no se cuenta
a través del mundo de las palabras
cae irremediablemente
en el mundo del olvido.
Y el olvido, no devuelve nada,
no sabría cómo.
Pero a las palabras, a ellas sí les gusta
llevar a personas por el viaje de alguien.
Llevarlas por un camino,
a veces lindo, a veces tétrico,
pero es un viaje al final de cuentas.
Hay que contar.
Contar aquello que estamos viviendo.
Porque cuando lo decimos en voz alta,
damos el primer paso para que una idea
que tenemos aquí en la cabeza
se convierta en realidad.
Porque cuando lo decimos en voz alta,
es un recordatorio constante
para los que nos escuchan y nos digan:
"Tú dijiste que vas a viajar."
Y yo digo: "Bueno, voy a viajar."
Tú dijiste que vas a
ser presidente de tal cosa.
Bueno, voy a serlo.
Dijiste que vas a acabar la carrera.
Entonces, lo voy a hacer.
Porque es un recordatorio
constante para nosotros mismos.
Porque lo que se dice
en voz alta, existe.
Y, si no me creen, solo
póngase a pensar en este ejemplo.
Imagínense que aquí hay una chica
hermosísima, bellísima, linda,
y yo, que la estoy mirando, y pienso:
¡Qué chica más linda,
qué chica más hermosa!
Creo que la amo, creo que la quiero,
y me empiezo a enamorar
y a enamorar, y a enamorar,
y la sigo viendo, y la sigo viendo
y no le digo nada y la sigo viendo,
y ella de repente se va.
Claro, no pasa nada si
solamente lo pienso.
Entonces tengo que acercarme
a ella y decirle:
"Hola, ¿cómo estás?
¿Sabes qué? Creo que te amo."
¡Claro!
Ahora, que me acepte ella
o que no, eso es otra cosa.
¿Saben? Soy cuentacuentos,
soy narrador de historias.
Y soy eso porque lo elegí.
Narro historias de la literatura,
de la tradición oral,
muchas de las escribo, de las que veo,
de las que vivo.
¿Pero saben también? Que yo soy narrador
oral, cuentacuentos, porque eso es
lo mejor que sabe hacer el ser humano
desde el principio de los tiempos.
Intenta narrar una historia.
La narra con números, con formas,
con música, con figuras,
con el cuerpo, con la voz,
con las palabras.
La narra y es cierto que, aunque se hayan
olvidado, Uds. también son narradores.
Son cuentacuentos y andan por el mundo
contando su propia historia.
Y creo que es tiempo de que cada uno
se siente y empiece a narrar quiénes son.
Para ese momento
el sol ya se estaba ocultando,
yo seguía en el café, con la chica,
y la andaba viendo.
Y ella me volvió a preguntar:
"Disculpa, ¿por qué no puedo
contar esta historia así?"
Yo la miré, y no tenía una respuesta.
Así que la miré...
y me dejé influir.
Más sintiendo que pensando, le dije:
"Lo que pasa es que cuando tú me
la contaste, yo me emocioné.
Y cuando te la conté,
también me emocioné."
Y aquí es donde va el secreto.
Todos los cuentacuentos del mundo,
y si conocen a alguno le van a preguntar
para que vean que es cierto.
Todos los cuentacuentos del mundo
saben que hay diferentes técnicas
para contar una historia.
El movimiento corporal, ritmo de la voz,
la dramaturgia de la historia...
¡uy, tantas cosas!
Pero lo que todos los cuentacuentos
del mundo tienen por principio y regla
es que la historia que vas a contar,
primero que nada, te tiene que gustar.
Porque cuando te guste, las palabras
no se atorarán en tu mente,
sino que tú serás simplemente
un lugar donde las palabras fluyan
y seguirán fluyendo, y seguirán
fluyendo y conectarán
con el que te está escuchando.
Y cuando la otra persona
se conecte con esa idea,
se conecte con tus palabras
y tu sinceridad,
algo empezará a cambiar.
Tú mismo empezarás a cambiar.
Y la persona que está escuchándote
también empezará a cambiar.
Porque cuentan los que cuentos cuentan,
que aquellas personas
que se atreven a contar
cambian el mundo con sólo nombrarlo.
(Aplausos)